hi everyone welcome to another episode
of Science and Technology q a fork kids
and others on this holiday-ish weekend
and I had actually forgotten I was going
to do this today but um
uh here I am so let's see what
interesting questions there are
um
oh my there's a question here about
superconductors and helices and
superconductors and so on
maybe I should explain something about
what superconductors are
so
when you have it's all has to do with
electric currents and materials and
superconductors are materials that are
where electric currents can go through
them with no resistance
so normally if you have a uh so what is
what is an electric current an electric
current is a flow of electrons from one
side of a material one end of a wire to
another
and normally there are
well there are different kinds of
materials there are insulators where you
put a voltage a voltage is kind of
putting pressure on the electrons it's
trying to push the electrons in a
certain direction
um and uh it's it's and it does that by
having an electric field and the
electrons move in the electric field
and are sort of pushed through the
material so
you have a voltage on a material and
insulators like something like I don't
know a piece of wood let's say or a
piece of plastic these are materials
where even though you may push the
electrons pretty hard by having a pretty
large electric field a pretty large
voltage the electrons won't go through
the material they'll just they'll just
get stuck and so you won't be able to
transmit a current you won't get a
current of electrons to go through so
even if you put a large voltage pushing
the electrons you won't get a
substantial current of electrons moving
through the material the other end of
the story are conductors
um like Metals where when you push on
the electrons so to speak by putting
this electric field putting this voltage
across the material the electrons just
happily follow the electric field and
flow through the material
in the middle of those two are
semiconductors that's a different story
but let's talk about insulators versus
conductors
the basic difference is when you look at
those things at a microscopic level
these solid materials let's say are made
from a bunch of atoms arranged in a
solid in some way so the atoms are sort
of just sitting there they may be
vibrating around a bit but basically the
atoms are fixed in one place in liquids
the atoms move around and gases the
atoms move around uh even more but in a
solid they're pretty much locked in
place the question is what happens to
the electrons so the atoms are there
sort of locked in place in an insulator
every electron is kind of allocated to
an atom and when you say to the
electrons you try and push the electrons
to move the electrons are locked into
their individual atoms and so the
electrons don't get to move
and a conductor what happens is that the
electrons from some of the atoms the
atoms are sort of close enough together
that some of the electrons from these
atoms kind of are in in states where
they're kind of shared between many
different atoms but technically it's the
the what's called in the conduction band
they are electrons that are not
localized to an individual atom the
electrons were kind of the the electrons
from different atoms are shared across
all the atoms in the material and and
that's why when you put an electric
field you're able to essentially move
electrons from anywhere to anywhere
because these electrons are sort of all
being shared between all of the atoms
the sort of official story of this that
involves quantum mechanics is a little
bit trickier and it involves the the
electrons in an atom are in a collection
of possible energy levels there aren't
it's not the case that the electrons in
an atom can have any energy they have a
discrete set of possible images that's
one of the lessons early lessons from
100 years ago or so now of quantum
mechanics is that that's the way things
work in the case of metals what happens
is that in this conduction band there
are sort of an infinite number of energy
levels that are all collected together
and so that means when you put an
electric field across the material it
makes the electron want to move a bit
and the the if there was a fixed
discrete set of energy levels the
electron wouldn't move unless it could
jump to another energy level and it's
because all these energy levels are kind
of crushed up together that it's
possible for the electrons to just get
moving with a uh with an electric field
that you might put across the material
just to just to sort of fill that in a
bit if you put enough energy into an
electron you can have it jump from one
discrete energy level to another for
example if it absorbs a photon of light
it can jump from one energy level to
another but the kind of energy is
associated with those photons are vastly
higher than the kind of energy
associated with the electric field that
would be you would get from you know a
six volt battery or something like this
so in any case the main point is that in
a in an insulator electrons are sort of
locked in place with our atoms and so
even though you might push the electrons
they don't move in a conductor like a
metal
um the electrons even with a a small
voltage will be able to move in the
material okay so the question then is uh
how much do they move
and um how big a current do you get for
a particular voltage
so it's kind of a standard kind of high
school physics formula called Ohm's law
the voltage equals current times
resistance that there is this property
of materials the resistance or
resistivity of the material that kind of
is the amount of resistance that there
is to the motion of the electrons and so
with a certain sort of pushing force of
the voltage there's a certain flow rate
of the material of the of the electrons
and the proportionality is this
resistance quantity okay so what causes
resistance so I've explained that that
these electrons are kind of delocalized
in the conduction band of a metal so you
just push them a little bit why don't
they just go straight through the metal
why don't they just uh you know you you
just give them a tiny voltage they'll
just zoom to the other end and and get
there well the reason they don't is
because the electron the the um uh there
are
uh the these electrons keep on getting
scattered so as they try and move
through the crystal lattice of the metal
for example if they move through that
solid the electrons kind of keep hitting
things they're they're sort of free to
move but as they move they're things
that they hit and then they'll deflect
and move somewhere else and um in
particular uh one of the things that can
um happen uh so they there are there's
for example in a material that can be
heat in the material what does heat do
heat causes the atoms and the material
to be jiggling around the the higher the
temperature the more jiggling there will
be and so that jiggling around means
that the the sort of the the the way
that one figures out this conduction
band and all these energy levels all
scrunched together that's sort of what
you would get if it was kind of a
perfect crystal lattice but it isn't
because there's there's temperature that
is causing the atoms to jiggle around
and so that's one of the effects that
causes the um
electrons to not just be able to go
straight through the material they keep
on hitting things in effect and um and
getting deflected
the story is actually a bit more
complicated than that because the whole
story of these of quantum mechanics and
these energy levels of electrons
um you can't quite think about it the
way that I'm describing but in a first
approximation that's right
um they uh
gosh let's see
um I'm just trying to see that I can
kind of down convert some fancy things
with things called Broan zones which are
a kind of a
um
there's a there's a number of kind of
buzzwords in this area there's a thing
called the UMP clap process
um which is a kind of
well actually let me explain something
so there are electrons which are
discrete particles of of
uh of electric charge and there are
atoms
in a material there's a kind of a
quasi-particle that one often talks
about things called phonons
and phonons are
essentially discrete deformations in the
material so just like a photon for
example is a discrete bundle of
electromagnetic energy that represents a
sort of piece of light piece of
electromagnetism when you're looking at
uh sort of deformations in a crystal
then it's possible in the quantum
mechanics way of thinking about things
to think about those deformations not as
just oh I'm twisting the material or
whatever but those things come in
discrete lumps and those discrete lamps
are called phonons and there's all of
these just like you can think about an
electron scatters against a photon and
things like that in a material an
electron can scatter against a phonon
what is a phonon a phonon is something
that is it's it's a discrete object in
the same kind of a way that for example
an Eddy in a fluid is sort of a discrete
object even though the fluid is there
and has all its molecules bouncing
around and so on you can still identify
oh there's this edgion it's moving
across the fluid it's the same rough
kind of thing with phonons in in solid
materials
anyway so the basic bottom line is when
the temperature of a material uh when
when you have a a
material with electrons and you have
this crystal lattice and has a certain
temperature and you have all of these
different uh sort of uh
pieces of the Crystal and so on
electrons will have uh will have a
certain chance of being scattered as
they try and move through the material
and that's what causes resistance to the
electric current that's what you're kind
of you keep on having to the electron is
going along it kind of hits something
it's sort of randomly scattered in a
different direction then you have to
apply that electric field again to say
no no electron you were scattered in
this random Direction but actually you
should be going in the way that the the
electric current is supposed to go and
so what ends up happening from that is
that the the um
uh your uh there's for any given
material at a certain temperature
there's a certain amount of resistance
that the electrons uh encounter as they
try and move them through the material
and that's what eventually leads to the
well resistivity is the amount of
resistance per unit volume of the
material
um and uh the the overall resistance
like if you're making an electric
circuit and you get a resistor the
little thing with with wires sticking
out of it so often little tiny things
but usually usually they're painted with
them uh this kind of um uh resistor
color code that tells you the size of
the resistor so a resistor might be a
one ohm resistor it might be a a million
Ohm exist resistor or it might be a
thousand ohm exist resistor ohms or the
units of resistance that tell you how
much in that formula voltage equals
current times resistance that's that's
telling you for that little object that
you pick up and put in your circuit
that's telling you how much resistance
there will be and therefore what the
ratio of the current to the voltage will
end up being in that circuit and and so
for example let's say you use a six volt
battery or something you've determined
the voltage now depending on the
resistance that will determine the
amount of current that flows through the
material uh flows through the circuit
and so for example if you're lighting a
light bulb for example what matters to
how bright the light bulb is as the
current that goes through it and so as
you change that if you have a fixed
voltage as you change the resistance
you'll change the amount of current and
so how bright the the light bulb is and
so on
so
actually there's a there's another well
okay if you fix the resistance that's
how it works
um okay superconductors
so ordinarily
um when you look at materials they will
have uh
their resistance
to electrons going through them for
example with Metals
um will progressively uh
decrease as the temperature of the metal
goes down but normally there is a sort
of a lowest level so remember that in
okay so temperature
is giving you temperatures proportional
to the average energy of motion the
average kinetic energy of molecules in
the substance
so there is and this was known even
pretty early in the in the study of of
gases and so on and by the by the
mid-1800s this was known that there is
an absolute zero of temperature that the
um uh that if you decrease the
temperature eventually the in a sense
the molecules stop moving and you get to
a place where there's there's
essentially no motion to the molecules
and that temperature is minus
273.16 or so degrees Centigrade or zero
kelvins
um the absolute zero of temperature now
tricky fact is that it isn't in fact the
case that all motion disappears at
Absolute Zero of temperature
um that's only true in classical physics
in quantum mechanics there is uh uh this
notion of Zero Point Energy and it's
it's not you there's always a a certain
amount of jiggling that goes on in in as
items even at absolute zero and so
normally
when you're calculating the resistance
of a metal or something and some of that
resistance is associated with kind of uh
hitting these sort of jiggling parts of
the material that jiggling doesn't go
away at absolute zero so even at
Absolute Zero normally there is still a
certain resistance
okay but there are special substances
called superconductors this was
discovered in the very beginning of the
1900s a special substance is called
superconductors which at sufficiently
low temperatures suddenly they have zero
resistance suddenly the all this
resistance that is associated with
electrons hitting things that are
driggling around in the in the material
goes to zero so it took a while to
figure out how that could possibly work
and it's an effect associated with
quantum mechanics and essentially what
happens is that the uh
normally every electron is its own story
it's going through the material it keeps
on hitting things it it scatters it has
to be sort of redirected
re-re-pushed by the electric field
um the uh
um but uh it every electron is kind of
acting for itself
okay so the phenomenon of
superconductivity is a phenomenon where
somehow the electrons start to act
collectively instead of it being every
electron for itself all the electrons in
the material are all the relevant
conduction electrons in the material
just decide we're going to act together
we're all going to go in the same
direction at the same speed and so on
um okay that phenomenon
as a consequence of a phenomenon called
bozeinstein condensation
which is a quantum mechanical phenomenon
and let's see if I can explain that uh
let me just say also it's um the same
phenomenon that leads to the possibility
of lasers with with photons and so on
uh let me try to explain what goes on
so
basically the the overall story is
when do particles like photons like
electrons decide that they're just going
to do their own thing versus whether
they do they decide that they're going
to act collectively
and the um
okay
this is now sort of diving somewhat
deeper into kind of fundamental physics
and Quantum field Theory and things like
that
but
um
there are two kinds of particles that
exist so-called fermions and so-called
bosons
uh now uh electrons are examples of
fermions photons are examples of bosons
I'm going to make a footnote which I'll
explain later
um in a superconductor the electrons
never act completely on their own the
electrons are paired up and things
called Cooper pairs
um so that it's like two electrons
together are the relevant kind of
particle-like unit for a superconductor
put that aside for a second
electrons on their own are fermions
um photons are bosons
you can decide for any given particle if
you say is it a fermion or is it a boson
you have to look at the spin of the
particles sort of intrinsic angular
momentum the intrinsic particles even
though something like an electron is
very tiny possibly of zip then the
traditional periods of zero size in our
model physics it's not quite of zero
size but it's still very small and you
can think of this thing as sort of
spinning around on its axis and you
would think if the thing is like imagine
it's like a top if the thing was really
of zero size it would have zero angular
momentum it has no kind of moment arm to
make angular momentum if it's of zero
size but uh in the in the funny way that
uh sort of tiny things work in quantum
mechanics it is still the case that you
can have a non-zero spin a non-zero
angular momentum even if the fingers of
zero size so things like electrons have
it has a half unit of of spin things
like photons have you one unit of spin
um the you could classify all these
different particles all the different
kinds of things protons are like like
electrons they have half a unit of Spin
and so on the things with half units of
spin a half three halves Etc all those
kinds of things are fermions the things
with integer uh whole number
um amounts of spin like photons and so
on those are bosons
okay so what well
okay there's sort of a fundamental
principle that fermions have this
property that
you can't put more than one fermion into
a single kind of quantum state
so for example if you say okay I've got
an atom and it's got a certain uh place
where an electron can go so to speak a
certain there's a certain energy level a
certain distance from the nucleus and so
on where the the sort of the the uh
where you can have this electron you say
well let me not just have one electron
there let me put a whole bunch of
electrons there it doesn't work you can
only ever have one electron in that
particular energy level in that atom and
that's very important for chemistry for
example that's what leads to you know
when you look at the periodic table
these these different shell structures
for atoms those shells get they get
filled up
um by the way it's because of the fact
that the um uh the electrons are
essentially sort of orbiting the nucleus
in different orientations you can have
not just one electron but different
numbers of electrons in these different
shells
um that are relevant for chemistry and
so what happens is the um
uh the electrons
um uh yeah there's there's some uh
electrons you can only fundamentally
have one electron in each sort of
particular State although there may be
in a particular shell there may be
multiple States and so on
and that's the result of this thing
called the exclusion principle that says
fermions never are prepared to be more
than one in the same state
and so
uh and and that's an important thing
because it's it's a large part of what
leads to the stability of matter for
example if it wasn't for the fact that
fermions aren't prepared to all be in
the same state matter would just
collapse but it's held up held apart so
to speak by the fact that there is this
Exclusion Principle it's one of the
effects it's the the main effect not not
the whole story the stability of matter
but but um one effect is this exclusion
principle that means that if you have
all these uh all these atoms electrons
whatever you can't just sort of crush
the whole thing down and have everything
just being in one state it has to be it
has to uh things that have to be in
different states and that's what leads
to the possibility of having sort of uh
matter that doesn't collapse
okay opposite story for bosons bosons
permians they refuse to be in the same
state together bosons collect into the
same state in fact if you've got a state
that has you know n photons in it the
probability that the that that state
always wants to collect more photons
into it the chance that another Photon
will go into that state increases with
the number of photons that are already
in that state
um so
in the case of bosons they all like to
collect in the same state
why does it work this way
well this is a complicated story and
it's I would say that this story is
beginning to be partially told from our
physics project in a more understandable
way but in standard uh Quantum field
Theory
uh boy this is a complicated story
um it's a thing called the the the this
relationship between the the spinner
particles half into just spin or
interest spin half and just been being
fermions would have Exclusion Principle
integer spin being bosons wherever
everything wants to collect together
that relationship is called the spin
statistics connection it's called
statistics because when you're sort of
counting the number of states that um a
system can have
when you count the number of states A
fermion system can have it's a system
it's you're counting things where
there's just one electron per energy
level and so on whereas with bosons you
can have any number and that leads to
sort of different statistics different
counting of states for those things so
this thing called the spin statistics
connection
um this uh was it was approved on the
basis of sort of the mathematical
formalism of quantum field theory in the
mid-1950s that it had to be the case
that there is
um this connection between statistics I
I might be able to explain this let me
see if I can
um
oh boy uh okay so
pump
well
he uh
um
this may get us let me not let me not
try and do this right now if people are
interested I will I can try and explain
this it's going to get us quite deep
into the theory of spinners and um the
ideas about rotation groups and then
into uh generalizations of relativistic
invariance and so on it's a it's a
slightly complicated story
um I think in our models of physics the
story may be much simpler
um but we haven't fully worked that out
yet
uh all right let's let's go back
where let's just say we take it as a
fact of nature that fermions like to
avoid each other bosons like to collect
in a single state
Okay so
as I explained
in electrons are actually fermions they
like to stay away from each other
but what happens in certain materials is
that it's sufficiently low temperatures
you form these things called Cooper
pairs which are electrons that are
paired up with each other they're at
least conceptually close to each other
they're not actually that close and it's
a slightly more complicated story in
what sense they're close
um but uh they're they're essentially
every electron has a partner and a half
inch just spin thing combined with
another half hundred just spin thing
makes an integer spin thing and those
integer spin things the Koopa Paz can
undergo Bose Einstein condensation they
will get to this place where the where
they all like to collect in the same
state
and that's what happens in certain
materials I think it was first
discovered in maybe 10 or bismuth I
think
um there are specific materials where
the structure of the crystal is such
that the right distances between atoms
and the electrons have the right energy
levels and so on so that when you go to
a sufficiently low temperature the
electrons pair up and they can have this
kind of collective uh Behavior okay so
what happens when they have this
Collective Behavior they basically all
move together and that means they can
you don't put you have to put sort of
arbitrarily small voltage because
they're going to overcome any sort of
imperfection material because they're
all kind of going going together and
that means that
you can have a a current that is
produced of electrons moving through the
material through a superconductor you
don't put you have to put a tiny amount
of voltage you can this current will
start going in fact the current will
keep going and people have
superconducting uh you know rings of
superconductor where the current's been
going around for years
and normally what would happen is those
electrons would keep hitting things and
eventually whatever energy was in that
current will be turned into heat because
they keep hitting things and they just
just make the molecules and the material
atoms and the material jiggle around
more and whatever energy was in that
flow of the electrons going around would
get just turn into heat and the and the
current would dissipate but in
superconductors that doesn't happen so
in superconductors the the current can
just keep going forever so that's an
important phenomenon because the um uh
that's very convenient you know if you
were going to let's say transmit power
from one place to another the it's you
have to uh you you it takes if the sort
of pump energy into the into the power
grid to just get the electric power
transmitted from one place to another
let alone used at the other end but if
you had a superconductor there you would
be able to just give it a tiny little
push and the electrons would all go the
current would go through the wire easily
now
okay the one big bug with
superconductivity is it only happens at
very low temperatures so I think the
highest temperature superconductors now
uh well the normal ones are around
um uh
they become superconducting I think
maybe 50 kelvins is that right
um that it's it's about uh uh minus 200
and something degrees centigrade is how
cold you need to cool the material to
make it be a superconductor and by the
way what happens is this sort of
condensation of Cooper Pairs and the
production of conductivity happens very
suddenly just like water boiling water
freezing there's a discrete phase
transition that happens when
superconductivity kicks in when you have
the temperature of the material
sufficiently Low by the way another
thing that goes sort of goes wrong with
superconductility is if you put a
magnetic field on the material there are
two ways to get rid of superconductivity
in the material one is to increase the
temperature of the material and the
other is to put a magnetic field on the
material both of those will eventually
destroy silicon activity in a material
and the magnetic field thing is kind of
a problem because that can mean that if
you put too big a current it could be
generating magnetic field and it can
destroy the superintended material okay
so superconduct has a used uh to have
this problem that you have to cool them
to very low temperature they're
definitely used in in places for example
one big use of them is a magnets
um when you make a magnet you have a an
electric current that's going around and
loop basically and that Loop of electric
current makes a magnetic field that's a
basic principle virtual magnetism and um
what you want to do is have as much
current go around uh for as little heat
being produced and the way to achieve
that is to make the um the the magnet to
be a superconductor and so lots of MRI
machines use superconducting magnets
they're used in particle accelerators
they're used people think about using
them for Fusion devices things like this
places where you need High magnetic
fields
um although as I say there's this
there's a problem that when you have
magnetic field itself can destroy the
relativity independent of of temperature
okay so there's been a sort of a big
effort to to um
figure out how high temperature can you
make superconductors and maybe 30
something years ago there was sort of a
big excitement because there seemed to
be high temperature superconductors that
um uh were being produced and one of the
things that's the biggest issue is the
temperature of liquid nitrogen uh
basically liquid air 77 kelins I think
um the uh is is something where you can
sort of cool things to that temperature
by having liquid air
um and that's you know it's cold it's
difficult to deal with liquid air but if
you have to go down to the temperature
of liquid helium which liquefies in a
much lower temperature it's much more
difficult to deal with things and so one
of the big issues is can you can you get
a superconductor that's even stays
superconducting up to the place where
you could cool it with lick of nitrogen
um and and then the real sort of Holy
Grail is can you make a room temperature
superconductor which where you could
actually use it where we could have you
know in your laptop you could have a
superconductor
uh that's not been achieved nobody can
show it's impossible far from it
um what has happened is even the high
temperature superconductors that were
discovered uh 30 years ago they're weird
materials they have a complicated
collection of different Atomic types of
atoms lanthanum a rather obscure element
was a was a big feature of at least the
early high temperature superconductors
um these are
this is um sort of the the race has been
on for decades now to find a material
where uh for one reason or another it
will turn out to be a high temperature
result nobody really knows how to do
that because the theory of high
temperature superconductors is not well
understood it took quite a while it took
a solid 50 years after superconductivity
was originally discovered in ordinary
Metals for the theory of super
conductivity to be developed and I don't
think there's a good theory of high
temperature superconductors yet it's a
difficult thing to work out you have to
deal with sort of the collective effects
of of lots of different particles and so
on and that's a hard thing to work out
particularly when it's all entangled
with quantum mechanics
so in any case in in superconductors
there are there are all kinds of
interesting effects I mean when you have
a little tiny Loop of superconductor
um you have these for example quantized
um uh magnetic flux so you can have um
uh sort of units of magnetic flux that
thread superconductor uh that there's an
effect a thing called Joseph's
injunctions
um the we can go into a long story here
this is something which was um back in
the 1980s was thought to be a possible
sort of future technology for for
computers was based on Josephson
Junctions and superconductors and so on
didn't really pan out at that time uh
spot amusingly it's kind of back because
that same technology with
superconductors and judges and Junctions
and so on is something that you can
think about using to make a quotes
quantum computer at least a computer in
which the effects of quantum mechanics
are important so it's kind of that
technology that that didn't work out
sort of back in the in the 1980s is now
back again because for that purpose
you know just to mention
superconductors and sort of related
phenomena
um well lasers are sort of a related
phenomenon in a laser all the photons
kind of all get in the same state so
they're all at the same frequency the
same color light they're all going in
the same direction the beam of laser
light is all just directed in one way
and the um uh
the way that um uh basically in a laser
you have to get all the photons to just
collect in this one state I mean that
the term laser stands for light
amplification by stimulated emission of
radiation
and what happens is I mentioned that uh
in the case of bosons which photons are
they there is a uh there's a higher
probability of going into a state in
which there are already photons and
basically lasers make use of that
um they the way they work is they kind
of pump atoms to a high to an energy
level where there will be photons that
are emitted to cause those atoms to
Decay down to lower energy states
but because of this effect of photons
liking to Clump together in the same
state what ends up happening is that all
the photons that are ready to Decay to
be produced that there are all these
atoms that are pumped up to this high
energy level and they're all going to
Decay down and as they Decay down
they're going to emit a photon but what
happens is because these photons kind of
like to be in the same state they all
kind of collectively jump down to that
low energy level together emitting
photons that are exactly in the same
going the same direction same frequency
and so on and that's kind of the idea of
lasers you're kind of pumping them up to
this higher level and then as the as the
as the energy levels Decay they emit
these photons which are all sort of in
the same state that's kind of the idea
of lasers the um
uh
the other kind of thing in that
collection is superfluids
and
in uh so helium liquid helium is the
sort of the the case study of the
superfluids
um normally
when you have a fluid it has a viscosity
so you know you have water for example
you start uh you you run your you you
have a jet in the water and you're
squirting water into water let's say and
that jet will go a certain distance and
after a while that jet will kind of uh
sort of dissipate away why well because
there are actual water molecules that
are in that jet and those water
molecules keep on knocking into other
water molecules which sort of randomly
scatter them in different directions
so they don't they don't manage to kind
of uh it's very much like the electrons
in a metal they're sort of randomly
getting scattered and so there's a
resistance to motion so the analog of
friction you know friction between Solid
Surfaces is that the motion that you
have between these solid surfaces is
being dissipated into heat eventually
the same thing happens in liquids
um where sort of you have emotion and
the um the motion of these molecules the
molecules are hitting other molecules
and everything's getting randomized and
that motion is eventually kind of
decaying away
okay in helium 4 and uh below the
so-called Lambda point of helium 4 which
is 2.7 kelvins I think uh I think it's
about two two point something degrees
above absolute zero
um when helium is that cold uh
the it has the same kind of effect that
you see in Cooper Pairs and
superconductivity and photons and lasers
that everything collects in the same
state
and um
uh and so these uh helium atoms that are
in the liquid helium normally they'd all
be going in random erections and so on
but when they get cold enough
it becomes a superfluid and all those
atoms act collectively they all kind of
go in the same direction and so that
means that they sort of have enough
oomph that they can overcome uh that
they they end up not being sort of
scattered around and they end up uh uh
basically making a superfluid a thing of
zero viscosity so viscosity is the
analog of friction for for fluids and so
you have a super fluid heat super fluid
helium you can have something just like
you can have a superconductor
superconductor that's an electric
current that keeps running for years so
you can have a super fluid where you'll
have a a flow of the of the super fluid
helium liquid that will just keep
flowing for years it won't it won't die
down it doesn't have viscosity just
keeps going it keeps going so that's
that's the phenomenon of superfluidity
um and uh uh that's um there are a
number of rather interesting effects
that happen from fluidity but by the way
another more recent thing was done maybe
20 years ago or so is to make Bose
Einstein condensates from ordinary cold
atoms
so in this whole classification of
fermions versus bosons
um certain atoms are uh have half energy
just spin other ones have integer spin
depends on the number of electrons the
number of protons nuclei the same way so
if you get the right type of atom so
that it has an integer spin then you can
expect that if you get these atoms cold
enough then they the whole clump of
atoms will all those atoms will go into
the same state and you will get one of
these bozein Stone condensates and
that's what was achieved almost 25 years
ago maybe
um and uh with them with actual ordinary
atoms of cesium and things like this
um and you know it's uh
um
the bosons and condensates are
interesting because it's kind of a a
large-scale object uh that is sort of in
a single Quantum State and you look up
one of these things I mean they they
just look like fuzzy white things
um suspended in in um in well in vacuum
usually
um but uh
uh it's um it's an interesting
phenomenon for exploration of quantum
mechanics and so on
uh now I'm I'm trying to
um
remember what the original question was
here
um
oh it's like helices okay so so
Okay so
yeah there's a there's a um
the thing's called type 2
superconductors which is probably what
you're thinking about
um
let's see
well things get there's a whole raft of
other things that come up so for example
there are when you put a magnetic field
through a superconductor
um sometimes you will get these kind of
flux tubes these places where the
magnetic field will be concentrated in a
tube in the superconductor because in in
a metal for example
um Metals kind of okay so what happens
is
okay you have a magnetic field
you have something like a bar magnet and
the bar magnet has a North Pole or South
Pole it has magnetic field lines and you
can kind of draw them they kind of come
out from one end and then they loop
around go back to the other end
um that's that's the so-called dipole
magnetic field is what you get from like
a bar magnet okay so what happens to
those magnetic field lines when in the
magnetic field when when you have a
material like a metal well a metal sort
of expels the magnetic field it it wants
the magnetic field lines all bunched up
on the surface of the metal and they
don't go through the metal they um
they're kind of um uh Metals sort of in
a sense uh
things are set up so that the magnetic
field
um just kind of goes around the edges
but it goes a certain depth into the
metal in a superconductor
um they are uh
oh my gosh I'm forgetting all this stuff
the um let's see these are
this is
yeah no I Okay so
oh yeah so there's three kinds of okay
for for
electricity they're a so-called they're
a dielectrics which are kind of the
insulators and there are conductors
for magnetic fields there are
um yeah this is fascinating I have kind
of computer controlled light system and
which is actually quite broken right now
because some board burnt out and at a
fixed time of day it will take about
five minutes it suddenly switches on
these lights even though this board is
completely fried so it's a weird
electronic Gremlin of some kind in any
case the um uh
uh okay so for for
magnetism there are three common kinds
of materials uh
diamagnetic paramagnetic and
ferromagnetic and it all has to do with
what happens when the magnetic field uh
sort of encounters the material
ferromagnetism is what happens when you
have like a bar magnet and where you
have kind of a where it generates its
own magnetic field
um uh diamagnetism it sort of pushes out
magnetic field paramagnetism
um it's uh you can
well let's see
uh
liquid oxygen is an example of
paramagnetic materials I remember
correctly if I remember correctly
um but the main point here is that
conductors tend to sort of uh
concentrate magnetic field
um and they will sort of push it out of
the um uh of of the interior of the
conductor when you have a superconductor
you've got this magnetic field that's
going through the superconductor it's
like well what's going to happen there's
magnetic field it's going to go through
the superconductor what happens is in in
this particular phenomenon it
concentrates into these flux tubes in
the middle of the super and little lumps
of flux tubes in the middle of the
superintendo and that's sort of an
interesting phenomenon because it's kind
of a weird thing that magnetic field
lines are being concentrated into flux
tubes why is that weird well if you have
an electric charge it's just sitting
there somewhere it has electric field
lines that go out from it like kind of a
an idealized Hedgehog they just go out
in all directions that's why there's an
Square law of electric attraction
because you've got these these um uh
these sort of lines of electric field
they're going out in all directions
you've got a certain number let's say
you had let's say you just think about
it in a discrete way you have a thousand
of these electric field lines right at
the at the object and then you go
further away they still have a thousand
electric field lines no new electric
field lines but the electric field lines
are distributed over the surface of the
sphere at distance let's say R and the
area of the surface of that sphere is is
4 pi r squared
um and uh that means that as you if you
say well how much electric field is
there in a particular uh in a particular
area as you go further out as you
increase the radius of that sphere that
you're going out the amount of electric
field per unit area goes down like one
over r squared and that's why there's a
number of square law of electric
attraction between things okay so
normally electric field just going out
in all directions and it's sort of
getting more dilute as you go further
out okay so something different happens
in a superconductor you concentrate the
electric and magnetic as it turns out
field lines but by the way the same
effect I just mentioned about the
electric field happens for magnetic
fields
um except that there are no magnetic
monopoles there are no isolated magnetic
charges like an electron it's just an
isolated electric charge in a bar magnet
you like have a North Pole like a plus
magnet thing and a South Pole a minus
magnet thing and they're always glued
together you can never saw off a
magnetic monopole
um in in there's a interesting physics
about about what would happen if there
were magnetic monopoles but there aren't
it seems in our universe magnetic
monopoles they always magnetic charges
always come in pairs plus minus Pairs
and so what is an inverse Square law for
a single monopole charge
um turns out to be an inverse Cube law
for a dipole charge if you have a dipole
which means a plus uh pole of the magnet
and a minus pole the magnet and those
are pretty close together and you're far
away from the whole thing
um those the plus sort of effects and
the minus effects sort of almost cancel
out but not white so you don't so and
you end up with a one over R cubed
effect
but anyway either way you've got a
decreasing sort of amount of kind of
magnetic or electric field lines that
are producing smaller and smaller effect
as you go further and further out okay
if you've got a superconductor that
doesn't happen because these flux
because the superconductor is
concentrating the flux the the magnetic
field and electric field into these
tubes okay so that means that you don't
get an inverse Square law you don't get
these kinds of things these flux tubes
have there's a fixed amount of flux so
however far away things are there's the
same amount of magnetic field that's
that's coming in there the reason that's
interesting is because it's analogous to
what happens in qcd Quantum color
Dynamics theory of quarks and gluons
um because
in that case for different reasons if
you have a quark S have a a thing called
color charge and color charge works just
like electric charge in the sense that
it's sort of basic properties that you
would have an inverse Square law of of
um uh
of of sort of
um attraction associated with color
charge
color charge photons other other
transmitters of electric charge
um that they're the well they're they're
the they're the sort of things that that
uh lead to electric forces
electromagnetic forces the analogous
thing for color charge is gluons and
um uh so sort of the simplest thing
would be oh the gluons all just go out
like like photons do and they're all
it's all kind of an inverse Square Law
of Attraction doesn't work that way for
gluons and the reason it doesn't work
that way is because the gluons unlike
photons photons don't really interact
with each other protons have no direct
interaction with each other if you shoot
two beams of photons in each other you
shoot two lasers at each other they'll
just go straight through each other they
won't the photons won't interact there's
a tiny effect it's called light by light
scattering and it's a tiny effect where
photons can interact with other photons
but for the most part other than some
sort of complicated Quantum field Theory
things that are very very small effect
photons don't they they don't directly
interact with each other
um and so
it's different for gluons for gluons
they they interact with each other
because gluons themselves have color
charge photons don't have electric
charge they are just things exchanged
between things that have electric charge
gluons themselves have color charge and
so what happens is the gluon is like oh
I'm you know I'm going to make this
whole stream of gluons going out to make
this inverse squirrel think well no
because all the gluons as they're going
out like that they're interacting with
each other and so they're clumping
together and essentially turning
themselves into flux tubes and so that's
uh and and the so what happens is when
you have two quarks and try and pull
them apart instead of there being sort
of an inverse Square law where the where
the quarks attract less and less as they
get further and further apart there's a
tube of uh of sort of chromodynamic flux
or something of color flux between the
the two quarks and that means that and
that tube never it it just gets it just
pulls harder and harder as the quarks
get further and further apart same type
of thing happens it's there's an analog
about that in type two superconductors
and and maybe that's what this question
about to helices was asking about
um all right that was a very long answer
to that question but that was um uh
um
okay there's a question from Akil can
you tell us why electrons in the atoms
of the sun do not burn due to the heat
of the Sun
I'll tell you an amusing fact about the
Sun I was I've been studying the history
of thermodynamics recently uh sort of
the theory of the Dynamics of heat
and people were very confused about how
the Sun could keep burning so in the
mid-1800s people tried to estimate the
age of the Sun and they tried to and
they thought well the sun you know it
started out as a burning thing right and
how long could it burn
and a thing of that size they estimated
could burn for those 30 000 years
and you know as people started saying
there are rocks that are millions of
years old there were still plenty of
people who were saying you know the
Earth was created in you know six
thousand years ago or something so that
fit in just fine with the theory that
the age of the sun was 30 000 years that
the sun could have been burning only for
had been burning for like 30 000 years I
think they thought it would burn for
another 300 000 years
um just based on you know it's a big
ball of burning stuff with ordinary kind
of burning
what was discovered only in the 1940s
and 50s was that the sun is um uh an
example of where nuclear fusion is
taking place
um burning is an effect that happens as
a chemistry effect it's an effect that
happens uh you know chemistry is all
about sort of rearranging the positions
of atoms and rearranging the electrons
that are parts of atoms
um nuclear physics is about uh messing
around with the nuclei of atoms which
are 100 000 times smaller than the atom
they're just the little piece in the
center of the atom that's a big clump of
protons and neutrons nucleophysics is
about doing things with that and what
happens in the sun is that there are the
primary thing that's happening is uh
protons from the nuclei of hydrogen
atoms are crashing into each other at
very high speed at maybe 10 million
degrees Centigrade
um uh that there and they're they're
being pushed into each other hard enough
that they fuse and as they fuse they
make helium and that process releases a
huge amount of energy much more than
anybody could imagine will be released
by any chemical process so that's that's
the main in process that's happening in
the sun and the main process is nuclear
fusion and and basically at the energies
that the Sun at the temperatures the sun
is at there aren't any atoms in the sun
all of the all of the uh everything has
been the electrons have all been
stripped off and they're quite they're
floating quite separately from the
nuclei of the atoms so what happens is
um
uh
the and so that the sun is what's called
a plasma same kind of thing that fire is
um it's a it's a thing where the atoms
don't have their their electrons still
attached the the electrons have at least
been partly in the case of fire partly
because the sun completely detached from
the nuclei
um and so there's no
um there's no notion of kind of burning
in the sense that um uh well okay so
what could happen is okay let me let me
mention some other some of the funky
things that happen
so
in the sun most of the energy of the Sun
comes from the fusion of protons with
other protons sometimes slightly larger
nuclei but mostly in the sun it's
protons and so protons are positively
charged particles and they have a
electric force of repulsion because like
charges repel and so normally when
protons two protons get near each other
they just bounce off
but if they're going fast enough that
you can kind of ram them into each other
they'll overcome that barrier associated
with the electric propulsion and that's
what you need in order to get nuclear
fusion and that's what that's why you
need high temperatures because they're
making the protons go very quickly okay
so one question will be what happens if
two electrons run into each other two
protons run into each other they'll fuse
together to make a helium nucleus for
example
um and uh if you if you had even higher
energies those that's what happens in
particle accelerators protons run into
each other and they'll produce a whole
spew of other particles pions and all
kinds of other things
um but uh in um
the energies of the something like the
sun that what's primarily happening is
that they're fusing to produce larger
nuclei okay so two electrons what
happens when two electrons run into each
other well they have they both have
minus one electric charge so they have
like charges they repel and basically
they just bounce off each other now when
they bounce off each other they are
coming towards each other they they kind
of they they're they actually what's
happening is they have an electric force
between them electromagnetic force
between them and you can think about
that as their sort of lobbing photons
virtual photons from one electron to the
other and that causes the electrons to
kind of Bounce the other way as they do
that they often emit a few extra photons
and so that can happen but other other
than that you can't get electrons don't
there's no there's nothing you get by
sort of fusing electrons together not
that we know at least I mean in the sort
of traditional
traditional modern physics I don't know
what to call it three what should we
call it I don't know uh you know because
in the last few years we've you know in
our physics project we've we've kind of
understood the next level of what one
has to understand in physics and um so
but the the physics that's been done
over the last hundred years is often
called modern physics they don't quite
know you know modern plus modern modern
physics or something is our stuff but in
modern physics as opposed to modern
modern physics
um the uh uh
it um electrons are just like
geometrical points they have no
structure they have no no no extent no
size
um at least not in any in any not
intrinsically they they have sort of an
effective size because they come along
with a whole gaggle of virtual photons
that that uh kind of a form of sort of
cloud around them but but in terms of
intrinsically they have no size
um and so there's nothing you can even
imagine happening if you even if you
have the highest conceivable energy
you're ramming electrons into each other
they're always just going to make you
know electrons again
um may not be true in our Theory uh
although the energies that will be
required will be outrageously high and
you know gazillions of times higher than
one could imagine making a particle
accelerator or than probably have
existed since the very first uh
incredibly you know trillion trillion
trillionth of a second after the
beginning of the universe so not a thing
you'd see most of the time but something
you might have been principle possible
all right maybe
um
uh
um
okay there's a number of questions here
about um
um
Parker's asking how does superconducting
magnetic levitation work
um
Okay so
what's happening is
when you have essentially it's just that
you could have better magnets and you
can have a magnetic field that is
produced by currents that are
circulating in uh in a superconductor
and because the superconductor doesn't
uh dissipate those currents the currents
will keep on circulating and the
circulating current will make a magnetic
field and that magnetic field can uh be
set up to repel the magnetic field of
another magnet and so you can levitate
something you can you know hold
something up and that people have sort
of talked about you know can you make
magnetic levitating trains and so on
that work using superconducting uh
magnets and it's it's easier well it's
not easier to do because you have to
cool a thing to like look at liquid
helium temperatures which is kind of bad
news if you want to make a long stretch
of Railway track but conceptually if
there were high temperatures if there
were room temperature superconductors
you probably could do that and one would
routinely have magnetic levitation that
will be really nice because the friction
if you are magnetically levitating
something
um and you can even do this with
ordinary magnets the the uh the
resistance to the motion is unbelievably
lower than if you have a physical
contact where you've got some you know
things rubbing against each other I mean
when you have things rubbing against
each other you can put a lubricant like
oil
um in between that will kind of keep the
the solid materials away from each other
so that they can kind of uh run past
each other more easily but in the
magnetic case you can kind of keep the
things actually physically away from
each other now there is still some
resistance to motion having to do with
uh effective Eddy currents and and that
are induced by the magnetic fields but
that's a different different effect
um
uh
Mr SW was asking about fermions and
bosons is hadron the intersection
between them no no hadrons are a
different category so fermions and
bosons it's just like anything with half
into just been it's a fermion and the
thing within to just spin it's a boson
so far as we know every particle that
exists is either a fermion or a boson no
exceptions so we can go down the list
you know the Higgs particle is a boson
it has spin zero the uh the W boson is
like its name suggests a boson it has
spin one
um the graviton is a boson it has spin
two
um the uh uh the neutron is a fermion it
has spin a half a proton fermion has
been a half each kind of nucleus has a
certain spin there are uh spin zero
nuclei
um which are bosons there are they're a
nuclei with spin 15 their nuclear would
spin a hundred actually
um and uh so long as it's an integer
it's a boson if it's a half integer it's
a fermion
uh okay so that's that's the sort of
category of fermions and bosons and
every particle is one of the other of
those another category another pair of
categories are leptons and hadrons
um so
that has to do with what kind of forces
those particles participate in so the
leptons are um uh
particles that only have electromagnetic
and weak forces they only interact
through the exchange of photons w bosons
z bosons actually Higgs bosons as well
but that's a different thing and
gravitons as well different thing again
all particles have those well all
particles that have mass interact with
um with Higgs particles and gravitons or
particles with energy interact with
gravitons but that's sort of a separate
separate bucket so the question is do
the particles have color charges which
cause them to interact with gluons and
so on
and the particles that do have I I
shouldn't say actually let me let me
back that up a bit so first category is
the leptons which are the electrons
neutrinos the muon the Tau lepton these
are particles that have electromagnetic
interactions and weak interactions
associated with the w boson and so on
um that they don't have strong
interactions strong interactions of
things like are the strong nuclear force
which is what holds nuclei together so
an electron isn't held into the nucleus
and that's why it can just be outside
the nucleus you know floating around 100
000 times further away than the than the
edge of nucleus so to speak
um that's because it's a lepton and it
doesn't participate in the strong
nuclear force so particles that
participate in the strong nucleophores
are called hadrons and all hadrons are
made from quarks or anti-quarks in
exotic cases they're just made from
gluons those are things called glue
balls which are a strange kind of exotic
part article
um but but basically hadrons are the
things that have things in them which
have color charge like quarks and gluons
um and they participate in the strong
nuclear force and that's that's that
category you know I was going to mention
one of the things somebody was asking
about
um burning of the Sun and electrons in
the Sun and so on here's a weird case uh
weird cases neutron stars
so stars were massive than the sun after
they have a supernova for example they
can kind of crunch down and they can end
up as just one giant atomic nucleus
basically it may be 10 kilometers across
has the mass of the Sun incredibly dense
um maybe a hundred trillion times denser
than water
um and uh it's just like one giant
nucleus and if you take nuclear the you
know the Sun and you Crutch It Down
you've got to have a bunch of protons in
there Etc et cetera et cetera the
protons and the electrons and so on that
are there they'd all get crushed
together and in the end what will be
left over is just a bunch of neutrons
and so you have this these things called
neutron stars which are
um
which are basically like giant atomic
nuclei 10 kilometers across made of
primarily neutrons there are a lot of
features of neutron stars that are
really weird so for example uh one
question is if you're a neutron star and
when you're formed the whole thing is
Contracting from this you know formed in
the Supernova it's really hot you know
there's the neutrons are whizzing around
they're really really hot how do they
lose that energy what happens to it
because they you know that there's
energy in this in this lump of neutron
matter
um how does it get dissipated and I
think it's because neutrons have zero
electric charge
well I'm not quite sure how this works
but but um uh I was just wondering about
this neutrons do have a magnetic dipole
moment they don't have they are like
little tiny bar magnets
and
maybe that can lead to the the fact that
they can imitate radiation I'm not sure
but one thing they definitely can do is
they can emit neutrino radiation and so
the interactions of those neutrons
through the weak nuclear force can
produce neutrino anti-neutrino pairs
um that are like the radiation that's
emitted you know you want to lose energy
or a neutron star emit a bunch of
neutrinos uh by the way that happens in
a supernova as well there's a giant
burst of neutrinos that are emitted and
a supernova and uh uh that that's
there's some signals that can be
detected uh it's difficult to detect
neutrinos they mostly just go straight
through the Earth at least at low
energies low energy neutrinos are the
kind that come from supernovas do that
um but you can a few times people have
detected signals from Supernova uh
explosions that just produce tons of of
neutrinos and that's presumably the way
that certain you know if you're if
you're a hot material with electrons in
it that are wiggling around and so on
you will emit electromagnetic radiation
it will glow red hot white hot blue hot
whatever that's that's emitting photons
because you're hot so to speak because
you've got these sort of atoms and
electrons moving around if you're a
neutron piece of neutron matter
um you don't get to emit electron and
photons same way and so presumably you
you glow you know neutrino red hot and
so on instead of instead of photon red
hot
um
as a question from Brady here actually
an interesting question I don't know the
answer to this
um
the uh asking is there much use for
superconductivity in space where the
temperature is already close to zero
Kelvin
uh
that is an interesting question
I have this recollection
well let's see
um there are some satellites I believe
the Planck satellite
for looking at the cosmic microwave
background
I believe it uses superconductor as well
it's it's trying to detect radiation in
that case that is right down at an
effective temperature close to the the
um uh well
down actually around the Lambda point of
a liquid helium
um it's uh
um
it uh and I think it's using uh I'm sure
it uses superconductors
um I mean the thing about about space
uh is yes the temperature of space
is about 2.7 kelvins it would be zero
but for the fact that there is microwave
radiation that was left over from the
from the Big Bang that has now sort of
cooled down to be as a result of the
expansion Universe
um to about 2.7 kelvins 2.7 degrees
above absolute zero
um now if you have an enclosed thing if
you you know that microwave radiation
you can absorb the microwave radiation
so you can have a box and inside your
box you can get down to uh to something
um much closer to absolute zero
um but I I'm I'm trying to think you
know the problem is as soon as you're in
the Sun so to speak things are going to
heat up a lot
um because there's radiant energy
um there's uh coming from the there's
radiation coming from the Sun as uh
electromagnetic radiation coming from
the Sun that heats things up so you know
there is a that's why for example when
you know when the polo Mission landed on
the moon
um Apollo 11 landed on the moon if you
look at where did it land it landed
right on the Terminator right at the at
the sort of dusk line on the moon
um right at the separation between
bright light and and darkness and that's
why you know when you see pictures of
the Apollo Astronauts they have really
long Shadows because effectively it was
it was right at dusk of the place on the
moon where they were and that was done
because if it had been in the sun it
would have been too hot if it had been
the in the the day it would have been
too hot night it would have been too
cold and that was that was kind of the
idea of that
um I think that um uh
um so I I'm I'm probably missing
something here there's probably some um
great
experiment or something that is that
makes use of superconductivity in space
but I'm not immediately coming up with
it
um Lawrence says I think superconducting
filters for actually my next signals
used in space it makes sense I I don't
immediately know it
um
uh
yeah Harry is commenting without
um an atmosphere around
um
yeah yes I mean you know when you look
at low temperature okay
here's another basic question how do you
make stuff cold
how do you reduce the temperature of
things
well
there are a bunch of ways to do it but
one good way to do it is a thing called
The Jewel Thompson effect when you have
a gas and you you know
squirt it through a nozzle the molecules
on the gas the the gas is expanding as
it goes out of the nozzle but the
molecules and the gas have some force of
attraction between them the fact that
they have a force of attraction between
them is not surprising because if you
lowered their temperature they would
just become a liquid and that happens
because the molecules have force of
attraction that's causing them to glob
together into a liquid but even when
there are gas they have a small force of
attraction between them and as you as
you you put them through this nozzle
they'll sort of be pulling back the um
uh slightly from
uh from and that that pulling back will
cause them to move less quickly which
means they'll have effectively a lower
temperature that's one of a bunch of
effects used to reduce the temperature
of things
when you get right down close to
absolute zero it's very hard to reduce
temperatures that low because
essentially what's happening is you know
heat is this random motion of all these
kinds of atoms and so on in order to get
to absolute zero you have to get rid of
all that random motion it's kind of like
if you could have a device that was down
at the scale of atoms and you could say
okay this atom you go knock yourself
into that other atom over here that's
going in the opposite direction then
you'll both be stationary maybe or you
might both bounce off but you could you
could um uh you know you can kind of
arrange things atom by atom so you do
this do that do that but we existed a
macroscopic scale and these atoms are
down at a microscopic scale
um and uh uh that
um and so it's difficult to reach
absolute zero in fact in the laws of
thermodynamics the third law of
thermodynamics from around 1906 I think
um says that it's impossible to reach
absolute zero with a finite number of
steps in other words you can you can do
one cooling stuff step into another
cooling step you'd have to do an
infinite number of cooling steps to
reach absolute zero to reduce to get rid
of all the heat to get rid of all the
randomness you'd have to kind of be able
to go through an infinite number of
steps another way to look at that is
there's all this Randomness and to get
rid of it you have to predict each piece
of Randomness and sort of get rid of it
and there's sort of an infinite amount
of computational work that needs to be
done to do that prediction and get rid
of the randomness now in practice I
think the method that's used
uh there are a number of funky methods
that are used to to do cooling I believe
there's a a refrigerator that's based on
some strange properties of liquid helium
uh I think helium-3 and helium four
helium three is helium where the nucleus
has a two protons and one Neutron helium
four the nucleus has two protons and two
neutrons
um helium-4 is a boson helium-3 is a
fermion and the interplay between those
two things leads to some funky effects
that have a form of uh there's a form of
refrigeration that's based on that I
think the most common way of getting
really close to absolute zero uh well
actually there may be some new ones
um that are used for cold atom
experiments for Bose Einstein
condensation but a very traditional one
is a thing called adiabatic
demagnetization
um which uh
has to do with changing the
um
uh sort of changing magnetic properties
of materials in such a way that you are
uh you're sort of absorbing the heat in
the way that you change the magnetic
properties and that's sort of a common
common way to get close to absolute zero
um
let's see
uh
so coming from pH aren't there Japanese
maglev Trends on which there are still
conducting cooling systems you know I
have this vague recollection that that's
correct I'm sure one can easily look it
up
um I I I think maybe that
there are I mean clearly you can you
know the magnets can be in an enclosure
as they are in an MRI machine for
example
um and you know they can be
superconducting so long as you can
circulate coolant
um a large enough area you could do that
I don't know if that's I have this very
good collection that that's been done
but I don't know if it's in production
or whether that's just a demo type thing
um
let's see well maybe one more thing here
uh
William is commenting I was talking
about flux tubes and type 2
superconductors commenting whether these
sharp in gravity
oh that's an interesting question you
see gravity like uh Quantum
chromodynamics has the feature that
gravity interacts with gravity
gravitones interact with gravitons
unlike photons unlike your
electromagnetic fields where the field
itself doesn't interact with itself in
the case of gravity like in the case of
quantum chromodynamics the field because
gravity is uh you know anything that has
mass or energy is a source of gravity
and so even the gravitational field
itself is a source of gravity and that's
that's kind of how
uh sort of one aspect of the way that
things like black holes are set up is
depends on the fact that gravity
interacts with gravity
um
can there be gravitational flux tubes
interesting question I mean there are
uh
they're a limited number
of different
um
types of of configurations of
gravitational field that are known the
most the most known well the ones that
are produced by various kinds of matter
there are ones that are black holes
which are vacuum Solutions where you
just have this lump of you could just
have a just a up we've got this lump of
gravitational field and it has it it
produces gravitational field itself now
in fact a black hole has this weird
feature that there can be anything
inside you don't know what's inside
doesn't matter what's inside but the
equations tell you what the structure of
the gravitational field outside the
thing that's inside and the weirdest
thing is there can be nothing inside
except for a single point where the
usual equations don't apply in our
models of physics it gets a little bit
better and more and easy to understand
than that but that's kind of the
traditional View so now a question would
be are there sort of tubes of gravity as
opposed to spherical configurations of
gravity when you have a spinning black
hole it does have it elongates but could
you have a flux tube a gravitational
flux tube
I don't know of solutions to the
Einstein equations that are that but
that doesn't mean they don't exist
because we certainly don't know all the
solutions Einstein's equations we know
Solutions with certain kinds of symmetry
like snorkel Symmetry and so we don't
know General case does that exist let me
think about that for a second
in higher Dimensions above three three
dimensions of space there are weird
things called black Saturns that are
kind of the analog of black holes in
higher Dimensions that they have they
have sort of ring-like structures but
I'm flux tube
um
I don't know
uh I mean the obvious thing to ask
in order to get a wormhole Solution
that's a somewhat different thing
wormholes need to be maintained by which
is a kind of a tubular structure but
they need to be maintained by negative
Mass matter
like talk energy and so on which may or
may not exist
um and uh but the question is whether
there could be something like for
example you might imagine
okay so with black holes
black holes you have two black holes
that are near each other they'll orbit
each other they'll lose energy through
gravitational radiation and they'll
spiral in and they'll eventually merge
and it's the black hole mergers that we
see in gravitational wave detectors
these days and it's like what is it one
a week somewhere in the universe and we
can detect that now a black hole mergers
of binary black hole systems now the
thing you might wonder
could you have something where sort of
you've got two black holes that are
going away from each other fast enough
and they're kind of somehow trailing
they somehow end up with a tube with
gravitational flux between them I I
don't know I I
can't immediately figure that out I've
not heard of such a thing but I don't I
can't say that it doesn't doesn't exist
or can't exist
um
all right I think
link asks a a somewhat different
question all right let me just address
this and then I should disappear here
um what do you think has the most
potential for changing the energy crisis
and what field do you think we need to
focus on to get there
oh I don't know I mean I think
I was reading a thing that was written
in 1900.
that was
bemoaning the fact that people were
burning coal and oh my gosh coal is
going to run out we should use wind
power instead
and that was a a very um vigorously
worded piece from 1900.
so
you know
the question of what
you know how does one get so so I mean
the thing to understand is
and in fact this piece from 1900 was
even making this point in the end all
this energy comes from the sun
now it might come from the Sun being
locked up in you know plants that had
photosynthesis let's say in the case of
coal you know back in the Carboniferous
period or whatever because of oil same
kind of period back in in geological
history you know all that energy came
from the Sun it got kind of burnt into
plants it got crushed so it's really
efficiently small and then we're mining
it out and sort of re-releasing the
energy of the sun
um which happened to be in a compact
form that we can put in our gas tank or
whatever
um and uh and release now
so you know the the source of most
energy that we can get is the Sun and
but our efficiency in converting the
energy of the sun to electric power for
example is rather bad photovoltaics are
not very efficient they're they're
um they're using
well we can talk about another time how
they are going to work but but um uh
I mean essentially it's it's photons
come in and they uh uh
uh produce
produce an electric current because they
sort of promote electrons to the point
where they can turn into an electric to
turn into a voltage and so on
um but the materials we know right now
are pretty inefficient at doing that
could there be a very efficient
photovoltaic material absolutely people
have been looking for them but they
haven't found them yet
um now when you come to uh
you know another sort of source there
are other sources of power like
hydroelectric power the power from Tides
things like that those I think are
fairly hard to harness and wind power
some of these things quite hard to
harness you have to build giant you know
wind turbines and things like this
um another source of lots of energy is
the temperature of the center of the
Earth
and you know that's again well it's not
quite the same as the the energy from
the sun because maybe half of the energy
that is locked up inside the earth comes
from when the Earth was first formed you
know 4.6 billion years ago or something
the earth was formed by this you know a
whole bunch of material just crunching
together as a result of gravity and that
material ended up being really hot and
you know the the that heat has not yet
escaped from the center of the earth
even though it's been for for a half
billion years and so that's some of the
heat of the inside of the earth some of
the other heat the inside of the earth
comes from the decay of radioactive
elements that's still going on because
they have half-lives of billions of
years like uranium uh 238 and things
like this uh you know 235 rather the um
the uh uh
in in um
uh and so so you know another way to get
power is you know geothermal kinds of
things and and that there are you know
people often when you say I'm going to
put geothermal stuff in my house it
means you're going to sort of drill down
and you'll get to the place where sort
of the soil is always or the underground
is always about 50 degrees Fahrenheit
sort of all year round
um just because the conductivity of the
of the surface of the Earth is not very
high and so sort of the the summer
winter variation just gets sort of
averaged out
but there's a much deeper kind of
geothermal energy that you get when you
drill down a few miles below the surface
of the Earth things are starting to get
hot eventually we go 50 miles down you
hit the the this uh maharovic layer
which is the separation between the
crust and the um uh and the mantle of
the earth and you end up with you know
and you end up getting to a point where
things are hot enough that there's
liquid rock
um but you drilled down a couple of
miles and you get to uh Rock that's
pretty hot hot enough that if you pump
water down there the water will boil
down there and get it back up it's like
a steam engine except that you don't
have except that instead of burning coal
or something you're um you're just using
the heat of the earth to heat things now
the challenge is how do you get enough
water or some other material some other
uh heat material to exchange heat how do
you um uh um how do you get um enough
um
um
uh enough stuff sent down this this pipe
and I I gathered there are a lot of very
practical issues like for example the
industry that has all the tooling to
drill a few miles down is the oil
industry and the oil industry has you
know tooling that's been being used for
100 years and it's very definite tools
you know like there's a there's a drill
there's a you know that there's the the
holes that you make the the boreholes
whatever that from drilling are a
certain size and you know all of the
equipment is is optimized to drill holes
of that size and that may not be the
right size for geothermal also there's
just sort of a a societal kind of thing
that the folks who do the oil drilling
um and the folks who who love geothermal
aren't necessarily don't mix very well
and so even though the geothermal folk
you know the thing they really need is
the technology of the oil industry
um it's kind of like oh we don't like
the oil industry but that that's um so
that's you know a very practical sort of
uh human issue but um uh you know that
that seems like a a that's a that's a
good thing because if geothermal works
it works anywhere on the earth it's just
using the heat of the earth a little bit
like the um a photovoltaic stuff more or
less Works anywhere on the earth unless
you have huge cloud cover and so on
um I think those are
those are some things now there's
nuclear power and standard nuclear power
uh from uranium
Etc
is uh that that's a thing that's just
engineering wise it's just pretty
difficult
um and you know building a nuclear power
station it's a very high-tech object and
people worry that things will go wrong
and things have gone wrong a few times
in the history of nuclear power
um I think we are in a very different
place in terms of our ability to usually
the things that cause Engineering
Systems to not go wrong are the ability
to monitor the system well I mean that's
what you know in the two big success
stories of kind of improving quality uh
were commercial airplane flying and
general anesthesia and in both of those
cases the number one issue was better
monitoring of what was going on you
don't have to kind of go look at the
tail of the plane to see there's
something wrong with it there's a sensor
that's telling you that and uh you and
and so I I do have the impression that a
modern a nuclear power station built
today with modern monitoring technology
it's much easier to have things not go
wrong than it was and the things built
50 years has gone more but I think the
um it's a it's sort of it's a high-tech
object and it has a lot of issues you
know radiation damages the metals that
are used to make things out of and that
causes a limit to the lifetime of things
and so on and it or can do and it's all
a kind of complicated story
um it's also you know people you can get
an awful lot of energy out of a fairly
small amount of uranium for example you
don't really have to mine the uranium
um it's uh
to you know you'll have to mine too much
of that of course it is still the case
whenever you're mining some particular
material uh one feature that is of
course complicated for the actual
geopolitics of the earth is that uranium
is not equally distributed around the
Earth
when the earth was formed there were
deposits of gold there were deposits of
tantalum there were deposits of uranium
there were deposits of other things
formed in particular places just like
oil was formed in particular places
because of the local topography and
geology at the time when when the when
all the trees got crushed to make make
the oil that we have today
um it's uh so you end up with a
situation where there's a lot of sort of
you know there's one place where
underneath that country there's a lot of
very valuable this that or the other
that's now getting mined and over under
another country sorry you lost out you
know when the earth was formed your
segment of the sphere just didn't happen
to get any useful material in it so you
know that was causes trouble and I think
that you know if nuclear power gets gets
a lot bigger that might end up being a
problem for that as well uh comments
being made so long as the nuclear plant
doesn't produce plutonium then it's safe
yeah I mean that there's a quite
separate issue which is that
um you know you can
you know nuclear material can be used to
make weapons as well as make electric
power the the the details of how you
turn it into weapons
are different from the details of what
you need for for nuclear power and the
kind of what you want for um uh and you
know you can have reactors that produce
um
well I guess the um
uh yeah I mean the the reactors produce
more material that is facile that is
capable of being used you can have
breeder reactors that make more material
that can be used for reactors
um so I actually don't know and I I now
realize I don't know for sure whether
whether one can set up a nuclear power
ecosystem where you never need more
material from the outside but you can
always produce your own material in the
end that can't work but um uh it can
probably work for you know if it works
for a million years we'll we'll consider
it a success
um the other sort of elephant in the
wrong kind of um uh source of power is
fusion power same power that that powers
the sun
um where you have
you have to get these materials we think
at very high temperatures like millions
of degrees centigrade and people have
been trying to do this for the last 70
years and there's a there's a hole I
think I've talked about this another
time there's a whole collection of
companies now
um as well as some government efforts
but more the companies I would say the
more uh more sort of we're going to make
it work soon type type story
um which believe that they will be able
to get nuclear fusion to work and if
that works well then it's a really good
source of
um of power
for the world
um and uh uh yeah I mean I I should have
talked about other things like hydrogen
power and so on and there's there's lots
of other uh specific things but if you
if you want kind of the Magic Bullet of
um you know just generate lots of power
uh I mean the problem with hydrogen
Powers you have to get hydrogen and the
way you get hydrogen is by uh by sort of
separating hydrogen from the oxygen and
water and that itself takes electric
power etc etc so it's a good way to to
bottle up energy but it's not
necessarily a good way you know you
don't it's not like you mine hydrogen
from somewhere all the hydrogen in the
atmosphere of the earth Escape long ago
we don't have the on Jupiter you know if
we were on Jupiter we could be
discussing you know having
um uh you know oh we just we just you
know guzzle in hydrogen from the
atmosphere but our planet doesn't have
that
um
let's see Parker's mentioning
thermovoltaic cells
I don't know what those are I can guess
what they are I mean there's a thing
called the thermoelectric effect which
was known 150 years ago another thing
called the Peltier effect which are
effects where the you get a voltage as a
result of changing the temperature of
the material
um and maybe that's what's being talked
about here I don't know of that as a
there are actually there are
refrigerators that work using that
effect
um and there are there are
um
I think you can run that effect
yeah I think as a matter of fact on the
deep space missions that used
um like the Pioneer spacecraft
that
um
use radioisotope not to actually a
radioactive material not actually to
make nuclear power but to make
electricity by just having uh heat there
and normally you make electricity from
Heat by having uh
uh you know gas turbines and things like
this but there's this other effect that
is this thermoelectric effect where you
can make
um make electricity from from purely
from heat and that's used for the
spacecraft why is it not used more
generally I don't actually know I mean
it's an effect that's been known for 150
years
um I suspect the reason is
that
it just it just doesn't scale very well
I think but I don't know whether there's
that's a problem of the particular
materials in which it's observed or what
it is I don't know good question don't
know
all right well I think I should uh
wrap up there
um and uh I see there were all sorts of
other interesting questions that came in
which I didn't have a chance to address
but we covered um all sorts of different
funky areas from um
from Quantum field Theory to electric
power and so on
um anyway thanks for joining me and and
uh Happy Thanksgiving weekend if you're
in the US
um and uh see you another time
bye for now